[Music]
we're desperate
for information about france
churchill has asked us to create a
secret army of spies
[Music]
this is a rudimentary operation women
will be more inconspicuous
make sure they're pretty for you or for
the germans
i don't believe we've met virginia hall
we could set her up as a journalist
good lord vera she has a wooden leg
would you suspect this girl's a spy
rumor has it you are the best wireless
operator in the women's auxiliary air
force
signaling is like music there is a
rhythm to it a pacifist and they are
teaching us to kill
they're training us to survive
we need you as our first female field
agent
don't be fooled common folks are
becoming collaborators
acquire information build resistance oh
gosh
and set france ablaze
if you have any doubts tell me now
this field is dangerous we're here now
seeing it through
we have no choice but to learn the hard
way how to do this
trial and
[Music]
a lot of error
go now the germans are locating our
signals faster than anticipated
we must keep trying
who is she i'm going to ask one more
time
the germans will stop at nothing till
they find you i'm not giving up
we're not giving up
it'll be here only for a short time
but what we do while we're here
[Music]
changes the course of the future
[Music]
you